hi everyone i'm jakobo simone's friend
the guy who made the previous videos i'm
behind the editing and scripting of some
of them for example the one about
colombia the idea behind this project is
to alternate our voices so in the future
you will often hear my broken english
but let's start our story begins on
april 17 1895. before this date taiwan
had never been under total domination of
a single power for the sake of briefness
we start off with the end of the 19th
century with the treaty of shimonoseki
in 1895 at the end of the first
sino-japanese war formosa as taiwan was
called and the pangu islands were given
inconcession to japan japan was very
interested in this islands as he wanted
to affirm its position as a colonizing
country so in reaction to what many saw
as a betrayal by china some nobles loyal
to the qing dynasty set up the so-called
republic of taiwan to resist without
success to the new rulers this episode
will provide one of the arguments used
by the current independentists against
the prospect of a new unification with
mainland china however with the advent
of the land of the rising sun any
connection with china was interrupted to
make room for the new demands and
political objectives of the emperor the
new occupants presented themselves as
the benefactors who would raise the
cultural level of a taiwan that
according to them was an urgent need of
reform in a few decades japanese rule
was instrumental in making taiwan a
modern colony in every aspect and on
this today most taiwanese agree japanese
imperialism is no longer seen as a dark
parenthesis to be forgotten but a
fundamental stage in the country's
progress which gave it a separate status
from both the expanding japanese empire
and mainland china in fact
infrastructures were improved public
hospitals were built the first paved
roads bridges big power plants and even
a railway line it was an all-round
modernization which also interested the
rural economy with the birth of the
first chemical industries to refine
sugarcane into sweetener and facilitate
the export on the japanese market after
the second world war the defeat of japan
meant that taiwan as a result of the
cairo declaration of november 1943
returned under chinese sovereignty and
precisely under the control of the
republic of china which was none other
than the kuomintang nationalist party
led by chang jeshi who was appointed as
trustee of the island on behalf of the
allied powers the nationalists
immediately sought tight control over
the economic and political life of the
island due to fear of japanese influence
of the pressures of reconstruction and
of the civil war on the mainland that
opposed them to the communists led by
mao zedong the central government relied
on a provincial administration composed
almost exclusively of mainland personnel
while the taiwanese tried to keep their
autonomy with the self-government a sort
of compromise between formal
independence and complete submission
from late 1945 to mid 1946 the
nationalists increased the tensions
between the provincial administration
and the local population to many china
appeared chaotic and backward as a
potential drain on the island's
resources and the threat to its
stability positioning itself in the eyes
of residents as a new but less competent
colonial ruler reintegration to mainland
china meant recolonization something the
taiwanese wanted to avoid at all costs
in early 1947 tensions between state and
society exploded in what became known as
the february 28 incident triggered by
the escape of a cigarette smuggler that
caused police officers who were in not
pursuit to fire shots to break through
the crowd protests in the following days
would allow the taiwanese to quickly
rest control of the island from a nil
prepared the provincial administration
but not for long because after just one
week a military contingent sent from the
mainland crashed all opposition and
massacred thousands of inhabitants from
that moment began the long period of the
so-called white terror which lasted 38
years during which the kmt tried to
suppress even in blood any form of
political descent arriving to imprison
and execute thousands of taiwanese in
december 1949 at the end of the chinese
civil war what was left of the defeated
nationalist party retreated to taiwan
thanks to us intervention that prevented
communists from winning the race
everything seemed to be turning to the
worst but the government was able to
promote a development that today is
known as the taiwanese miracle between
1960 and 1970 thanks to measures such as
rent reduction expansion of education
land reform the introduction of a stock
market and banks that encouraged foreign
investments in taiwanese companies the
value of imports and exports increased
dramatically and the average annual
growth in gross national product
registered the 9.7 percent with a per
capita gdp growth rate of 6.6
unlike the dark period of the 1950s when
income distribution in taiwan was much
like that of mexico or brazil
characterized by a wide gap between the
poorest and richest citizens by 1970
taiwan's income distribution was among
the most equitable in the world better
even than that of the united states it's
not surprising that foreign countries
found in taiwan a valuable resource a
skilled well-educated and highly
motivated workforce who saw in these
measures a unique opportunity to give a
better life to their line of succession
with this in mind the authoritarian
regime had little to fear that at some
point the residents would revolt and on
the off chance that this would happen
law enforcement would promptly be used
to suppress any descent this situation
of unconscious submission let's call it
that would only taper off from the 1980s
onwards when the middle class which had
grown thanks to economic development
began to exert more and more pressure on
the state for a democratic reform in
fact the big problem was that only a
minority of the population participated
in political life precisely 15
corresponding to the military and
civilian elite who came from mainland
china together with chang and
established themselves at the top of all
aspects of society again confining the
locals to a secondary status if we step
back a few years we realized that
stability had begun to falter in 1971
when the republic of china lost its seat
at the united nations to the people's
republic of china and so most states
recognized the latter as the sole
legitimate representative of all of
china and this making a big leap into
the present day brings us to the heated
dispute between taiwan and mainland
china the fundamental question here is
whether taiwan the pangu shinmen and
matsu islands should remain part of the
territory of the autonomous republic of
china or be unified with the territories
now ruled by the people's republic of
china it all depends on the answer to
the following question is it legitimate
to recognize the republic of china as a
sovereign state you need to know that
taiwan is strongly penalized on an
international level we are dealing with
a de facto state that is not recognized
as independent neither by the prc nor by
the other permanent members of the u.n
security council and that on paper
maintains diplomatic relations with the
only 14 states that recognize it beijing
for its part considers it a chinese
province out of its control the result
of the dynamics of the cold war when the
united states prevented mao from
annihilating the nationalists a fact
that allowed them to migrate to the
island and keep the republic of china
alive in order to stabilize relations
between the two sides of the strait
without renouncing the reunification of
the chinese territory beijing has
imposed adherence to the principle of
the existence of a single china the
so-called one-china policy in practice
any state wishing to establish or
maintain relations with the prc must
recognize the china with beijing as the
only existing china and therefore deny
sovereignty to taiwan and not have
official diplomatic relations with it
adhering to this request the vast
majority of countries including the
european union member states maintain
very close but unofficial relations with
taiwan and therefore in many cases
cannot offer taiwanese institutions or
businessmen the same conditions normally
applied to others on the opposite front
taipei authorities claim instead to
represent a fully sovereign government
mind you however that since 1949 when
the constitution of the republic of
china came into force formosa adhered to
the one china principle claiming
sovereignty over the territory now
governed by the people's republic of
china along with outer mongolia but in
1991 after a series of revisions the
kumitanga reduced its claims recognizing
that its powers were limited only to the
areas under its control a further
approachment with the political
trajectory of the prc was then the
adherence to the so-called 1992
consensus whereby beijing and taipei
agreed that there was only one china but
agreed to have a different
interpretation of what said china was
whether the prc or the republic of china
more recently the fear that taiwan could
fall into beijing's orbit has triggered
the mobilization of taiwan's civil
society starting with the more than 3
million young citizens between the ages
of 15 and 25. sea experiences such as
the sunflower movement which in march
2014 marched over 500 000 people leading
to the occupation of parliament and
briefly the seat of government this is
the result of widespread discontent
arising from some important phenomena
such as social inequities rising
unemployment difficulty in finding a
suitable job after studies and
especially the ecological degradation
that plagues several areas of the island
regarding this last aspect of crucial
importance for environmentalists where
the terrible earthquake of 2011 in japan
and the subsequent tsunami that caused
the accident at the fukushima nuclear
plant events to which taiwanese public
opinion and media have given great
prominence given that the island of
formosa is also located in a highly
seismic zone and has at least four
nuclear plants three of which are
located in the municipal area of the
capital tebay in any case disrupting the
status quo in terms of foreign policy
has been the rise of the democratic
progressive party led since 2016 by the
first female president cyinguan her
approach and willingness to reshape the
1992 consensus were seen by beijing as
favorable to a process of independence
and generated an immediate reaction as
in 2017 the southern chinese border
hosted at least 1
500 missiles aimed at the island however
taiwan has those who protect it with the
signing of the taiwan relation act in
1979 in fact washington committed to
defend the sovereignty of the island
providing constant military supplies
that would act as a deterrent for a
possible clash this is because the us
has always considered formosa a
fundamental strategic junction in the
south china sea but how is it possible
that the united states has official
relations with both beijing and taipei
didn't we say that one excludes the
other well yes in theory but in practice
this is possible thanks to a series of
interpretative devices of the agreement
with which the americans have
established diplomatic relations with
the prc back in 1979. in fact the prc
continues to believe that by adhering to
that document the americans have also
implicitly accepted the prc as china
alone but washington doesn't think so
since it has never expressly followed
this interpretation however the us have
managed to not disappoint neither
mainland china nor taiwan on the one
hand they have never expressly supported
taiwanese independence aspirations
meeting the favor of beijing and on the
other hand they have continued to pursue
their policy of deterrence maintaining
close cooperation with taipei the
prospect of a conflict in the strait is
not ruled out although not very
convenient for both actors given the
huge volume of trade between the
taiwanese industries in chinese
territory but if this were to happen the
fate of taiwan would be quite
predictable assuming there is no
interference from outside let's put it
in this way in 2017 chinese military
spending was about 145 billion dollars
and active troops amounted to more than
800 thousands compared to only 130 000
taiwanese not to mention that taiwan's
air force doesn't seem to be able to
compete with china's new chengdu j-20
stealth fighters the navy on the other
hand is the real flagship of the
taiwanese army but it has constant
difficulty in modernizing its
technologies for certain sectors due to
the blockades that beijing imposes on
military companies in 2021 for the
chinese communist party centenary
beijing has again put pressure on taipei
with at least 600 air raids of which 150
in the first week of october alone
seeing that the invasion is imminent is
too difficult to predict according to
the words of the taiwanese defense
minister beijing would have the
capabilities to annex the island by 2025
but not to undermine the sector of
essential goods called semiconductors of
which taiwan is one of the largest
producers for such reason china may
think twice before excluding the
diplomatic route and we are done today i
hope i gave you a clear idea of taiwan's
recent history that's what mattered
we'll definitely be hearing about taiwan
again and again in the coming months see
you in the next video bye